So the system,
Allah home in space,
we live in a peaceful part of the Milky Way.
Our home is the soda system of four and a half billion year old formation that
races around the galactic center at 200,000 kilometers per hour and circles it
once every 250 million years.
Our Star,
The sun is at the center of the solar system.
It's orbited by eight planets,
trillions of asteroids and comets and a few dwarf planets.
The eight planets are divided into four planets like ours,
mercury,
Venus,
earth and Mars,
and four gas giants,
Jupiter,
Saturn,
Uranus,
and Neptune.
Mercury is the smallest and lightest of all the planets.
Uh,
mercury year is shorter than a mercury day,
which leads to enormous fluctuations in temperature.
Mercury does not have an atmosphere or a moon.
Venus is one of the brightest objects in the solar system.
And by far the hottest planet with atmospheric pressure that is 92 times higher
than on earth.
An out of control greenhouse effect means that Venus never cools below 437
degree Celsius.
Venus also doesn't have a moon.
Earth is our home and the only panel with temperatures that are moderate enough
to allow for a surplus of liquid water.
Furthermore,
it's so far the only place where life is known to exist.
The Earth has one moon.
Mas Is the second smallest planet in the solar system and hardly massive enough
to keep a very thin atmosphere.
It's Olympus.
Mons is the largest mountain in the soda system more than three times as high as
Mount Everest.
Mohs has two small moons.
Jupiter is the largest and most massive planet in the solar system.
It consists largely of hydrogen and helium and is the theater for the largest
and most powerful storms.
We know
it's largest storm.
The great red spot is three times as large as earth.
Jupiter has 67 moons.
Satin is the second largest plan is and possesses the smallest density of all
the planets.
If you had a sufficiently large bathtub,
satin would swim in it.
Saturn is also known for its extended very visible ring system.
It has 62 moons.
Uranus is the third largest planet and one of the coldest of all the gas giants.
It's also the smallest.
The special thing about Uranus is that it's axes of rotation is tilted sideways.
In contrast to the seven other Palettes,
it has 27 moons.
Neptune is the last planet in the solar system and is similar to uranium.
It's so far removed from the sun.
There's a net you near is 164 earth years long.
Then
the highest wind speed ever measured was in a storm on Neptune at just under
2,100 kilometers per hour.
Nip tune has 14 moons.
If we compare the sizes of the planets,
the differences between them become even clearer.
Jupiter is the leader in terms of size and weight.
Small Mercury on the other hand is even smaller than one of Jupiter's moons.
Gunny meet Jupiter is so massive.
There's a loan.
It contains roughly 70% of the mass of all the other planets and has a massive
impact on its surroundings.
That's a blessing for earth.
Since Jupiter draws most of the dangerously large asteroids that could wipe out
life on earth,
but even Jupiter is a dwarf in comparison to our star.
The Sun calling it massive.
Does Not do justice to the sun.
It makes up 99.86% of the mass in our solar system.
For the most part,
it consists of hydrogen and helium.
Only less than 2% is made up of heavy elements like oxygen or iron.
At its core,
there's some fuses,
620 million tons of hydrogen each second and generates enough energy to satisfy
mankind's needs for years,
but not only the eight planets orbit our son,
trillions of asteroids and comets also circle it.
Most of them are concentrated into two belts,
the asteroid belt between Mars and Jupiter and the cup of bell to the edge of
the solar system.
These belts a home to countless objects.
Someone's launches,
a dust particle authors the size of dwarf planets,
the most well known object in the asteroid belt is Sarah's.
The most well known objects in the Khyber Belt aren't Pluto make,
make and Haumea?
Usually we described the asteroid belt.
It's a dense collection of bodies that constantly collide,
but in fact,
the asteroids aren't distributed across an area that is so indescribably large
that it's even difficult to see two asteroids at once
despite the billions of objects in them.
The asteroid belts are fairly empty places and nonetheless there are collisions
over and over again.
The massive both belts is also unimpressive.
The asteroid belt has a little destined,
4% of our moons mask and the Kuiper of belt is only between one 25th and one
10th of Earth's mass.
One day the soda system will cease to exist.
The son will die and mercury,
Venus and maybe earth too will be destroyed
and 500 million years it will become hotter and hotter until at some point it
will melt Earth's crust.
Then the son will grow and grow and either swallow earth or at least turn it
into a sea of lava.
When it has burnt up all it's fueled and lost most of its mass,
it will shrink to a white dwarf and burn gently for a few billion more years
before it goes out entirely.
Then at the latest life in the solar system will no longer be possible.
The Milky Way will not even notice it.
A small part of it in one of its arms will become just a tiny bit darker,
and mankind will cease to exist or leave the solar system in search of a new
home.
Okay.